today we're going to talk about global
wind patterns
wind determines more than just the best
places to fly a kite global wind
patterns help control where it rains
what kinds of species can survive in an
area and even where tropical rainforests
and deserts are located in other words
global wind patterns are really
important to life and one of the reasons
we have global wind patterns at all
is actually because of the sun
sunlight shines on the earth like this
as you can see the sunlight hits the
equator directly but the light hits the
north and south poles at an angle kind
of skimming the surface
like this
so the equator is getting direct
sunlight
and the poles are only getting in direct
sunlight
with all the direct sunlight the air
around the equator gets really hot and
the air around the poles doesn't heat up
as much because it's only getting in
direct sunlight
and you may be thinking what does this
all have to do with airflow
let's take a closer look at the equator
to see what's happening
so imagine you're standing on a piece of
land near the equator
when the direct sunlight hits the
equator
the hot air near the ground begins to
rise up
because hot air rises
all the direct sunlight also causes
evaporation to increase
which means that this air that's rising
up right here is both hot and moist
but once all this hot moist air reaches
a high enough altitude it begins to
expand and cool down the water vapor in
the air begins to condense into clouds
and it eventually falls as rain around
the equator
the air which is now cool and holds less
moisture sinks down to the ground
because cold air sinks
and the cycle repeats with the hot moist
air rising and the cool dry air falling
and the fact that the hot air rises up
means that this area right here is an
area of low pressure
of low pressure
because the air is rising up it creates
a space for cooler air in surrounding
areas to move in and take its place
and over here
where the cool air is coming down to the
ground that's an area of high pressure
because all of that cool dry air is
coming down and pushing the air below it
away this cyclical movement of air
creates something called a convection
cell
a convection cell
if the earth wasn't spinning we would
just have one convection cell in each
hemisphere
where the air would heat up at the
equator
move up towards the poles and sink down
and in the 18th century this was how
some scientists believe global wind
patterns worked
but
because the earth is spinning the
earth's rotation pushes air masses from
east to west
this movement of air creates a clockwise
pattern in the northern hemisphere and a
counterclockwise pattern in the southern
hemisphere
this is called the coriolis effect
and this movement of air because of the
earth's spin
causes us to actually get three
convection cells in each hemisphere
these two the two closest to the equator
are called the hadley cells
they're between the equator and the 30
degree latitude marks in both
hemispheres these next two
are called the feral cells
or the temperate cells
and these are located between a 30 and
60 degree marks in both the northern and
southern hemispheres
and lastly we have the polar cells which
as you can probably guess are right by
the poles
so we have polar cells up here at the
north pole
and we also have polar cells down here
at the south pole
and these convection cells create
prevailing winds that move heat and
moisture around the earth
let's take a look at what happens on the
bottom half of each convection cell the
parts closer to the ground because these
parts are closer to us we experience the
air movement as wind
so on the bottom of this convection cell
the hadley cells the cold air is moving
towards the equator
so that means that the prevailing winds
would also be moving towards the equator
winds are named after where they come
from
so these two winds
are called the northeast and southeast
trade winds because they come from the
northeast and southeast and they move
west
and the bottom halves of the feral
convection cells take cool air from the
30 degree line and pull it towards the
60 degree latitude line
this creates the westerlies
and they're called the westerlies
because they pull air from the west to
the east and the bottom halves of the
polar convection cells take the cool air
from the poles and sweep it to the 60
degree latitude lines and this creates
the easterly winds
it's important to remember that
everything in this diagram is just an
overall model
global wind patterns are even more
complicated because water covered areas
and land covered areas absorb solar
energy differently
these prevailing wind patterns
distribute heat and precipitation
unevenly between the tropics temperate
and polar regions of the earth
and this uneven distribution creates
different biomes
and this helps determine which species
can survive where
the tropical rainforest will be in the
low pressure areas near the equator
and right here between the polar and
feral cells is another area of low
pressure
just like near the equator hot moist air
rises here causing more precipitation in
the surrounding areas
so along this latitudinal line you'll
find many coniferous forests that thrive
because of all that precipitation
and there's a high pressure area right
here where the cool dry air sinks down
so there is not as much precipitation
the air is drier here you'll find many
deserts along this line and this line
so even though convection cells and
prevailing winds are invisible
the ways they shape the environment are
not